[Musique]
parle plus vite que ça toi d'abord je
m'appelle sarah connor le 29 août 1997
devait être le jour du jugement dernier
mon fils john et moi avons empêché sa et
sauver 3 milliards de vies c'est
suffisant comme cv à tes yeux
pas vraiment
tu as peut-être changer l'avenir mais
t'as pas changer notre destin c'est quoi
au juste
j'en avais jamais vu des comme toi
presque humaine je suis humaine mais
améliorées que les choses soient claires
j'ai pour mission de la protéger si tu
la mets en danger
je te crève la peau procès
je prends le volant
je vais faire un gros but pour passer je
suis une vraie arme ont vu leur épargne
nous des phrases de drague
désolé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je reviendrai
écoute c'est par malheur tu ne t'en sors
pas tout le monde va mourir
comment on arrête ce truc on ne le
combat pas
on le fuit
sarah est ce que tu crois au destin si
on gagne pas cette fois
tout est fichu
tu sais quand on en aura fini je te
tuerais